Three years old, and I don't know why I brought that up,
probably 'cause he does choreography.
He does, he's so good.
Okay, welcome back.
We were just talking about Justin Bieber during the break.
Who doesn't like Justin Bieber?
I mean, nobody on planet Earth.
I know, right?
Justin Bieber, if you're watching this,
you're my favorite singer.
We all have Bieber fever!
Bieber fever!
The Beliebers.
Yeah, we are the Beliebers.
Are you a Belieber?
I've gotta be.
Yes!
Well, we are Beliebers of toys.
And our toy expert Maddie Michalik was giving us the scoop
on all the toys we need to have for this summer,
for fun in the sun.
And our dear friend of the show, Leo Kelly,
is here giving us his thoughts on the toys.
Now, Maddie, what have next?
All right, so we're gonna talk about Swingin' Shoes.
Now this is a really fun game
that you can play inside or outside
no matter what the weather is.
So this is a new take on the classic game of horseshoes.
But here's the twist,
it is suspended in the air
either from a tree or your door frame.
So as you are getting your horseshoes on the platform
it's gonna be moving,
so it's extra challenging.
Yeah, it sounds it.
You guys wanna give it a try?
Yes, please!
Here are your horseshoes.
The good thing about these
are they're not like 500 pounds
and they're not made of metal.
They're rubbery.
Very kid friendly.
Yes.
So everyone can play.
I hear you there, Leo.
Just if they hit your head
they don't hurt.
All right.
You wanna try it?
Are you guys ready to go?
Yeah.
You wanna go first?
No, you can go first.
Okay, Leo.
Oh, nice.
Oh!
Oh, good job, yeah!
There you go, Leo.
So you can land
fitters, bringers.
I'm making this one for you.
I'm making this one for Drew so it's even.
Oh, wait, did I just knock that other one off?
No, it's still there, don't worry about it.
Okay, I will say this, this game is totally addictive.
It is addictive.
Yeah.
You just wanna keep going over and over again.
You're like, "The next time I'm getting it."
Oh!
God, okay.
Oh, I hope this makes it!
All right.
Oh God, Leo, you did it!
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, darn it!
Okay, what is our last summer item?
(audience clapping)
Yeah, so there's no such thing as summer fun
without a nice, refreshing, Icee.
That is true.
But now you can make it
in your own home with this Icee machine maker.
That is so cool.
So all you do is add water,
your favorite flavor of syrup, and some ice,
and then you have the perfect slushy every time.
I mean, Leo Kelly, you are the Shirley Temple king.
What are your thoughts
on this toy?
Yeah, we have
a special cherry flavor.
This was made for you.
Yes.
I mean, it literally is.
Let's try it.
And we're gonna cheers to the summer, guys.
Let's go!
Cheers, everybody.
Thank you so much.
What do you think, Leo?
This is so good.
Thanks to "Toy Insider,"
you're all gonna go home with everything
that you see here today.
(audience cheering)
So I hope that you guys
enjoy your eight-foot giraffe.
And we can all use a little light,
a little fun, a little sun,
a little magic, a little toys.
We all deserve this.
So thank you, "Toy Insider."
And thank you, Maddie Michalik
for doing that with us.
Thank you for playing today.
And, Leo, oh, I love you so much.
This is gonna be the best!
Thank you, everybody,
so much for choosing to spend your time with us,
because I promise you with all of my heart
we make this show with our heart and we make it for you.
So please, take it with you.
(upbeat music)